yo what is up everybody my name's
prestige and this is another episode of
divine survival series RPG now actually
one sec Oh normally I don't do this but
I am currently exporting up videos we
kind of got to turn down the stuff since
I'm run on old minecraft I don't have an
opt to fine so I can't make everything
all perfect frames and anyways hello you
especially being new to the series well
chances are you aren't but it's not like
I'm super pipe in series but my my fans
seemed like it my subscribe people seem
to enjoy it thoroughly now I last
episode we had created for I had all
those ladders in there and I didn't use
any of them shame on me for wasting
missile horses materials or resources
last episode we built that house that's
cool smiley face and this episode I
didn't even think about what we're gonna
do so we're just not thoughts gonna do
hmm we're going to destroy the land over
here that's what we're gonna do and now
the reason you might ask well prestige
by doing this I am doing this because I
want to like build something over here
eventually so I want to like start like
a civilizing all this land so did you
that I gotta start to shore and stuff so
I'll be I'll be just showing this land
and that's basically what i am doing at
the moment sure I'll and got to make it
nice and level and luckily this chick ax
destroys everything the overworld like
two seconds I'll take a little bit
longer on take it destroys all the dirt
in the world new seconds all right i'll
destroy you see let's see look at that
look that destroy so yeah have you guys
been tell me the comment section below
how have you guys been she can get all
smiley guy I've been freaking collect in
any wood yet legit i clicked my first
would awesome so yeah i'm gonna
eventually want to build something here
it might even be in this episode but we
don't know we don't know what the future
holds in store for us not a psychic
don't ask me then ask me bruh bruh so
yeah this is cool
I'm every place all this stone dirt and
make it all nice and level well I really
clear this out a bit let's push let's
push this back even a little farther
even a little bit farther now that means
tree you got to get out of here you go
on with your tree up no I don't want
that want that all right and yet to be
honest well but John aha did you did it
today into the flitter did it look good
there's just like a march like some
circus song all right Alex haha that
looks normal ish you're just covering
some dirt dared luck there that looks
normal normal say all right now up I
gotta make that look kind of normal
unless I build rakes wit I even
regardless we could make it look a
little bit a little bit more normal yeah
Troy and then let's destroy this this
layer we're going to basically make it
look like a staircase
a staircase of normal done everything
must be normal normal forever now we
just got a dish or this you see that
really doesn't look normal so you got to
make some indentations okay tree you're
going private ray is that you had a nice
life you provided shade lots of
caterpillars so pretty there really is
another piece this is a difficult tree
it's not want to die it might help to
look where I'm going yeah that to the
tree okay there we go to trees dead all
right that's good and then like destroy
it is for this and just try this bit
more and try this and this fat that Oh
looks pretty good I said sure yeah it
looks good I not announced blip replace
all this stone with dirt II did it did
it did it did it did it did whoa what
the heck man I just drop I cool again
apologies for the lag because I am
exporting like I'm gonna leave I talked
about in the other video I'm leaving
tomorrow to the east coast for two weeks
so I'm gonna do my best to have these
videos like pre courted to be sent out
there just check my mic is not mute I
one time I record an entire video and
like was on mute that was a little bit
aggravating but yeah so I think we're
going to be pairing the land and then
we're gonna build like it like Todd
house here no we're to have a house so
yeah I'm just going to build it it's
like building but it's fun
doot-doot-doot it did it did it look a
bit fair but I should have enough dirt
because I Canada Shore lots and lots of
dirt know what I'm so little bit of
dudes tired oh my gosh that's like
freaking this this is where people can
see heroin and jump out of the spring
two inch away mints the fog no not Kabul
we call it dirt I have lots of dirt I
did not mean to break the dirt stop it
stop for dirty again on my nerves dirt
Wow placing blocks is like II feel like
you're Sherlock should have been lying
here but yes placing blocks is like or
then destroy and oh my death fall is
already kicking in huh cheese and
something healthy not much with the
frames what the heck lowered you that
like help if the circumstances I
wouldn't blow with you at all this I
want to push this back a little bit I
don't like you then I'm going to replace
this stuff with a dirty
2 2 2 TD Liddy also tell me if you guys
like uh if you like me building and
stuff since I I could like me building
that I'll continue to build it and i'll
be like more building than venturing but
it is an RPG so we'll do adventure in
but uh if you don't like buildings and I
like I've seen as a lot of their you
other youtubers other even minecraft
youtubers there are people seem to
really like them when they build stuff
and I really don't have a facebook page
and so I can't really pull and you guys
aren't that active I don't think know
where I don't know but to like take
polls they go what do you guys want to
see so i'll just ask you what do you
want just tell me in the comment
sections since that's the best way for
you guys to tell me what you want just
just let me know in the comments and get
that that perfection let's get some more
dirt gonna have to put a lot of this
dirt away and that looks pretty good you
see now we have it all this area and we
can start insert a nice little nice
little like every unlike build stuff
yeah so yeah i'm gonna make a little
make a little i'm going to make a little
fishing Hut that's what i'm going to do
make a little hut for fishing yeah it's
gonna be the best I should me to get
ready and then a problem will be in this
episode this is this absorbs commentary
that I gotta love my voice I throw some
dirt in there throw some Turin I'm not
really organizing that much apologies to
people who are like crazy organizer
people I'm pretty sure the seeds going
here yeah um sand Sam's a blocks and you
are there let's throw some cobble can
anyone tell so some more Calvin your
gravel gravel a word i think i could put
in here some wood or don't have any
special spots for that miscellaneous
through you and you it's organized it's
just a bit more
mm-hmm all right we need some wood let's
see what should I make it out of I'm
gonna make it out of I shall break a
little brick [ __ ] outpost don't have
enough brick I don't think I'd break
let's see what what could I make out of
oh shush would make it out of what to
make it mmm-hmm at the rack that's an
option I could do without a boo and
stone nothing in Sun looks like good how
did I get that hello get a piece of the
end portal oh I'm just a hundred mater
okay well why is this man I have lots of
you over here um do not know what to do
another brick mm-hmm shall make out
another break
hmm you ask me got network delete the
dark mysterious forgettin dark
mysterious fisher shack can i make like
other another nether brick stuff awesome
another brooks lab i'm gonna wake it up
can we gotta make stairs can i legit
let's get some slabs and let's get some
stay at all yeah buddy Oh perfect I need
more I'll just come back here alright
guys so next episode we will be doing
the hardcore fishing shack and it might
even be more like in this with a bateria
listen I'll be exporting to of it is hmm
are you guys well I hope you enjoyed ah
see my face hope you enjoyed this
episode it's a building I'm going on
building Palooza if you did if you made
at the end of this video I always think
that if someone makes it all the way
through especially one of these longer
long videos like 10 15 20 30 minute
videos you get the end of it I think you
liked it enough to give it like so I
really appreciate a like comment rate
and if you're new subscribe since that
would be awesome so my name is prestige
hope you guys enjoyed this and I'll be
sketching you later